all thing is a scam as US President
Donald Trump continues to attack the
impeachment investigation another
witness has refused to show up acting
White House chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
is the latest in a string of White House
officials to defy requests by Democrats
to testify in the Congressional
impeachment inquiry get over it
Democrats want to talk to Mulvaney about
statements he made last month he told
reporters Trump deliberately held up
military aid to Ukraine to pressure it
to investigate Trump's political rival
former Vice President Joe Biden we do we
do that all the time with foreign policy
Mulvaney later walked back those
statements and Democrats want to know
why Mulvaney was one of 13 witnesses
scheduled to testify in closed-door
hearings this past week just two showed
up as Congress moves toward the public
phase of its investigation to begin next
Wednesday Trump says he's opposed to
those hearings well they shouldn't be
having public hearings that contradicts
Republican members of Congress who
stormed a closed-door session recently
protesting the private hearings and have
asked for more openness Democrats
alleged Trump abuse presidential power
when he spoke in July with Ukraine's
leader the call prompted a whistleblower
complaint the foundation of the
Democrats impeachment inquiry Trump
released a transcript of the call he
says shows no wrongdoing he's
considering releasing a second
transcript of another call with
ukrainian President back in April I had
a call I make a lot of calls but I have
no problem releasing it I'm very
transparent Democrats allege just the
opposite there's a heck of a lot of
evidence that the president's committed
impeachable offenses but we have to give
a fair hearing if they try to be
open-minded and then say next week the
world will hear publicly from key
witnesses in this investigation one of
them bill taylor has confirmed privately
what Donald Trump has vehemently denied
the Trump hide Ukraine aid into an
investigation into former Vice President
Joe Biden
Kimberly hellcat al-jazeera the White
House